I assume you've researched all the EMF blocking products on your website. I am just so skeptical
that a sticker works on a cell phone or jewelry, as mentioned earlier, really works. Well,
I said over and over again that nothing is going to block the EMFs. Well, I should take them back.
Yes, if you put your your phone in a Faraday cage, that's what a Faraday cage is. This is a completely
blocks all reception. So those little, those little cloth, um, Faraday cages. So a Faraday cage is
anything. It's not cage, but anything that blocks EMFs, like truly blocks EMFs. So how do you
know if it blocks EMFs? If you put your phone in our bag, you know, that we have, you know,
unless you're standing pretty close to a tower, you won't get it. You won't hear the, if
somebody calls you, it won't go through because it's blocked the communication. You know, and we have
on our store bags that you can put over your, your, your internet box in the house and it can help
block that, but the problem is you, if you block your internet, you won't be able to use
your internet in your house. So you can't completely block stuff. If you blocked, if you had your
phone in a Faraday cage and you completely blocked, you can't use your phone. So well, that's what I
want. I just gonna, I just want my phone to shut off so that I can't receive any messages. Okay,
well, then that's where you get those bags and you can put your phone in a bag overnight. So
you can't get any calls. Well, I'm hesitant personally to do that because we got, you know, a bunch of
kids with the bunch of grandkids and, you know, there's an emergency and they have to call us
at the end of the night. We wouldn't be able to get their calls. We would, it's not as full as this
turned off. It can't receive anything. So it's completely blocked. So what's, to me, the best
alternative then is honestly those, the safe sleeves are my favorite. We used to sell them,
but then there's too many different qualifications at different folds. So there's too many skews to keep
when we just stop selling the sleigh. So I tell people just to go on them to safesleeve.com would get
it. That's what I use on my phone. It's kind of a hard case. So it's not to be able to like it because it
increases the bulk of your phone, but that's what, that's the best block edge where you could still
receive messages. Now I have a safe sleeve and a sticker on my phone. The stickers don't block
EMS nor to the pendants block EMS like I stated before. They're just helping change the
negative effects of the EMS. So you don't have as many negatives. Nothing is going to do it completely
unless you put your whole body into a fairy day cage. So nothing's going to work. None of those
things are going to work perfectly. So it's just the way it is. We live in a world full of bad frequencies
that are going through us.